[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue ici à Kef nous
sommes avec le président wolo dimmer
zenenski bonjour monsieur le Président
merci de nous accueillir ici dans votre
palais présidentiel fortement sécurisé
c'est une pièce que connaissent des
millions de téléspectateurs on reconnaît
quelques caractéristiques de cette pièce
vous adressez régulièrement au monde
depuis cette pièce où nous sommes cette
émission est réalisée dans les
conditions du direct donc depuis keV en
léger décalage elle est diffusée sur TV5
Monde TV5 Monde monsieur le Président
c'est 403 millions de foyers 22 langues
et 200 pays qui donc peuvent nous
regarder aujourd'hui et également sur
LCP qui est la chaîne d'information
politique de l'Assemblée nationale
française cette émission est réalisée en
partenariat avec de grands groupes de la
presse quotidienne régionale française
je vous présente Patrice Moyon
spécialiste de l'Ukraine à Ouest-France
je vous présente Denis carreau le
directeur des rédactions du groupe Nice
Matin et Armel Le Goff qui est
directrice de la rédaction de 20 minutes
monsieur le Président première question
comment allez-vous comment tenez-vous
comment va votre forme physique
mais
bonjour Tout d'abord
je veux remercier de cette possibilité
de parler avec nous de dire de parler de
ce qui se passe en Ukraine
de
403000 foyers
c'est énorme je me sens comme n'importe
quel citoyen de l'Ukraine nous sommes
les mêmes nous se sentons de la même
manière nous connaissons notre but nous
sommes confiants dans notre victoire
à chaque jour nous
sommes sur qu'il est le plus important
d'avancer nous avons l'initiative
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas du tout simple
c'est difficile il y a les moments
tragiques quand on perd nos concitoyens
mais nous sommes sur l'histoire
on s'habitue à cette vie
oui je me suis habituée à cette ville ça
va
mon état physique dépend de chaque
personne on peut dormir pour
5h mais quand même
trouver le temps pour faire des
exercices physiques vous avez le temps
de ça pour s'entraîner je pense que
c'est important je pense que c'est très
important et je le pratique alors
bientôt 8 mois monsieur le Président que
votre pays est en guerre attaqué par la
Russie alors les premières heures de
cette tentative d'invasion de cette
invasion de cette tentative vous dites
cette phrase devenue très célèbre dans
le monde entier aux Américains qui vous
proposent de vous exfiltrer de votre
pays vous dites j'ai besoin de munitions
pas d'un chauffeur est-ce que vous avez
vraiment prononcé cette phrase et à qui
est-ce que c'est au président américain
qui vous pose la question à qui cette
phrase devenue plus célèbre
président
des États-Unis
on avait on appelle
il était le premier à m'appeler
parmi les leaders internationaux après
le début de la guerre
[Musique]
et un peu plus tard on a commencé à
recevoir
les messages à propos de l'évocation de
ma famille et de moi de plusieurs
leaders ils avaient les mêmes réponses
les mêmes
propositions
il a été surpris de votre réponse
il s'attendait à ce que vous quittez le
pays
tout ça
en utilisant les figures de langue je ne
me rappelle pas je ne me soutiens pas
qu'elle était la réactions du Président
bayden je me rappelle le conte de du
soutien militaire il a répondu que
c'était ma décision et
elle respectait ma décision on en
parlait plusieurs fois après le début de
l'invasion la grande échelle tout le
monde a compris mâchoire je pense
mercredi encore monsieur le Président
des tirs sur la centrale de saporidja ce
qui préoccupe le plus aujourd'hui les
opinions publiques dans le monde en
Europe aussi particulièrement c'est le
risque nucléaire une question de Nicolas
faucon du groupe Centre France la
montagne notre partenaire
où en est-on du projet de sécurisation
de la plus grande centrale nucléaire
d'Europe
merci pour la question
qu'il y avait des bombardements mercredi
mais vous devez aussi savoir qu'il y
avait des kirs et de frappes près de
l'autre centrale
[Musique]
nucléaire
c'est un risque
la Russie a occupé cette centrale
nucléaire aujourd'hui il y a les
employés
Ukrainiens mais ils sont plus en otage
par les Russes parce qu'il y a 500
combattants russes sur le territoire de
la centrale et c'était confirmé déjà par
Russie par les EA ils étaient
500 de combattants russes
nous avons des chiffres exacts 500
combattants maintenant le central est
déconnecté c'est encore risque
techniques sont là-bas c'est pourquoi
nous recevons les informations
proposent l'état actuel il lutte pour
se mettre en fonction en bloc mais la
Russie n'est pas intéressée dans le
fonctionnement de la centrale parce que
comme ça nous pouvons aider à l'Europe
donc la première tâche
c'est de priver les oblages des
apparitions
nucléaire et la plus grande en Europe
vous avez raison elle a cible nucléaire
qui génère l'électricité
en général nous avons 15 blocs
nucléaires à Ukraine donc cible c'est
une grande partie et vous devez
comprendre que sur mobile en bloc
explosé
comprendre tous les risques leur
première tâche c'est de nous privatiser
de l'électricité
mais c'est pas assez maintenant quand
nous ne sommes connectés au réseau
européen nous parlons de
l'approvisionnement de l'électricité à
l'Europe
la Pologne l'Allemagne la Roumanie et
les autres pays c'est un grand soutien
surtout dans la période d'hiver c'est la
deuxième chose que veut la Russie c'est
de priver l'Europe et le troisième
risque c'est le risque d'explosion
nucléaire des catastrophes nucléaires
nous devons comprendre
la situation et ce journaliste et la
question à propos de l'état actuel donc
la centrales est complètement déconnecté
mais qu'est-ce que vous dites quand vous
entendez les Russes dire que vous avez
aussi des responsabilités que vous avez
aussi tiré sur cette centrale de sa
pourriture
a confirmé que le crâne ne contrôle pas
la situation sécuritaire sur la centrale
et autour de la centrale
il y a les combattants et
l'armement en plus notre nos employés
techniques ils comprennent ce qui se
passe au niveau technique
non pas assez d'expérience
professionnelle assez d'expérience
techniques pour travailler sur la
centrale
c'est pourquoi
allumer
la centrale
le mettre en fonction et peuvent aussi
terminer le travail des blogs parce
qu'il faut éviter tout risque
rien les employés Ukrainiens ils
assurent le fonctionnement mais ils
n'ont pas non plus et ne peuvent pas
prendre les décisions les combattants
dans les ordres monsieur président il y
a les sites nucléaires mais il y a aussi
l'arme nucléaire mercredi matin Vladimir
Poutine a un nouveau menacé d'en faire
usage vous auriez dit ne pas le croire
qu'est-ce qui vous permet de penser
qu'il ne ferait pas usage de l'arme
nucléaire
je ne crois pas que le monde va lui le
permettre
donc nous parlons des camps payés
européens et l'influence de l'Union
européenne à la Russie les États-Unis
les contacts de la Grande-Bretagne et
l'influence sur la Russie
beaucoup de pays
la Turquie et l'orthogan y compris ils
sont en contact ils surveillent la
situation sécuritaire
c'est la même chose pour la Chine qui ne
peut pas rester en différents
peut faire des mains hier il a dit qu'il
fait une solution diplomatique pour la
guerre et aujourd'hui il commence la
mobilisation
mais le président de l'esquine n'en veut
pas
pour lui dire la vérité ou mentir c'est
à peu près la même chose je pense qu'il
ne comprend plus
mais
il comprend très bien que ces
référendums vont exclure tout dialogue
dans le futur
monsieur le président Vladimir Poutine
vous l'avez évoqué à décréter mercredi
la mobilisation partielle son objectif
c'est d'envoyer 300.000 hommes
supplémentaires sur le front il y
arrivera-t-il et est-ce que cela peut
changer le cours de la guerre
je pense qu'il arrivera à envoyer cette
quantité d'hommes
je pense que je
l'évoquais déjà
ne partenaires et non service de
renseignement ont reçu des informations
on veut que
ces fichiers c'est document pour 300000
hommes ont été préparés
bien avant que la mentionné la
mobilisation
donc maintenant vous pouvez voir la
réaction du peuple russe les
manifestations et ils sont arrêtés
je pense que les Russes font une horreur
ils ont peur d'être emprisonnés
aujourd'hui pour
les manifestations
c'est le soutien et tout ceux qui
descendent dans les rues ils ont peur de
d'être emprisonné mais ne comprennent
pas ce qui peut leur arriver quand il
arrive
sur le sucriniens et nous devons tirer
sur sur ces gens
soit et
[Musique]
quand j'en ai prisonnier donc il ne
comprennent pas les différences pour
faire les manifestations aujourd'hui
c'est plus sûr et c'est nécessaire parce
que c'est comme ça que la démocratie
marche et même si tu es privé de cette
démocratie
[Musique]
Patrice Moyon monsieur le Président deux
courte question sur les horreurs de
cette guerre mercredi vous êtes exprimé
par vidéo devant l'Assemblée des Nations
Unies vous avez demandé la création d'un
tribunal spécial pour juger les crimes
russes pourquoi est-ce que vous ne vous
appuyez pas sur la Cour pénale
internationale c'est la première
question et la deuxième question
une coalition d'ONG a souligner
l'utilisation massive par la Russie des
armes à sous-munitions mais soulignent
également que l'Ukraine y avait eu
recours est-ce que vous êtes prêts à
signer la convention d'Oslo interdisant
l'utilisation des armes à sous-munitions
je peux vous répondre oui parce que je
voudrais avoir les mêmes armes que notre
ennemi c'est tout pour se protéger et
quand tu vois les chars tu ne peux pas
les arrêter avec
les
armes légères dans les projets à jour de
la gare les gens descendaient dans les
rues et essayer d'arrêter les chars avec
les mains vides
[Musique]
donc on ne peut pas justement
arrêté des colonnes de char russe avec
des moyens rudimentaires on a parlé de
drones civils que des jeunes de soldats
utilisés pour ça donc vous avez réussi
au départ à stopper l'invasion russe par
des moyens
relativement rudimentaire amateur
j'allais même dire
nous sommes réunis on faisait tout pour
arrêter les troupes russes avec tous les
moyens mais
ils utilisaient les bombes
il y a déjà des investigations il y a
déjà des confirmations et c'est une
réponse partielle à la première partie
de votre question pourquoi nous
utilisons un certain mécanismes nous
utilisons tous les mécanismes que nous
pouvons nous utilisons
tous les moyens nous organisons les les
investigations conjoines nous sommes
ouverts pour tout processus
international nous voulons créer un
tribunal spécial pour juger les crimes
de guerre comme il parlait russe parce
que l'histoire n'a pas connu le tortures
dans cette quantité il démembre il
demande les gens ils violent ils
commettent les les assassinats en masse
donc soyons déjà
pas maintenant
je voudrais juste que vous compreniez
des choses très simples
et je voudrais qu'on soit très
pragmatique avec cette guerre aucune
conversion ne travaille pas ne marche
pas avec la Fédération de la Russie
aucun accord avec la Fédération de la
Russie n'a pas été
il y a des conventions il y a les
conversions de Genève il y a des
documents des accords différents
il y a même les accomp concernant l'état
de
prisonniers par contre les Russes nous
donnent les prisonniers
sans partie de corps les Russes peuvent
faire ce qu'ils veulent ils détruisent
les gens à olagna il ne le cache même
pas
c'est la garde
même si nous sommes en guerre nous
acceptons les règles de cette guerre
et les connaissent aussi mais il
n'observe pas cette règle qui va
garantir les conventions qui vont être
signées alors qui va les garantir si
vous ne croyez plus du tout dans la
signature de Vladimir Poutine qui va
faire ce travail de garantie
[Musique]
je peux vous donner un exemple par
exemple on a
signé un accord de l'initiative de
céréales pour l'exportation des céréales
nous avons dit que qui dans votre esprit
quelle est l'institution internationale
qui va garantir d'éventuelles signatures
par exemple d'accords
on peut parler de différents aspects de
cette guerre tout d'abord je voulais
dire que quand on commence à discuter
d'une seule d'un seul problème dans
cette guerre nous pouvons se mettre
d'accord
d'une troisième partie pas directement
avec le Russie
et l'oignon va poursuivre prenez pour
parler avec la Russie c'est comme ça que
ça a marché nous avons l'accord avec
l'oignon et l'oignon un accord avec la
Russie
[Musique]
n'a pas d'un accord signé avec la avec
l'Ukraine ils sont déjà avec la Turquie
et l'oignon mais d'accord on va parler
de notre chose ce qui peut marcher
c'est pas un accord qui peut marcher
avec la Russie mais
la capacité de répondre avec la force
[Musique]
il faut montrer la force il faut isoler
la Russie
le monde d'affaires le tourisme
les technologies à la Russie
la première
dans le monde qui sont prêts à envoyer
leurs soldats pour nourrir je pense
qu'il n'y a plus de termes comme ça dans
le monde ça leur est égal ce qui passera
avec leurs hommes
uniquement la force qui peut nous aider
sur toutes les directions dans tous les
aspects la force du point de vue
économique du point de vue de sanction
de l'armement dans ce cas ce sera une
convention et un accord le plus fort
possible
les négociations ils auront une position
différente
qui dans les conditions du direct ici
dans son palais présidentiel fortement
sécurisé sur TV5 Monde et sur LCP
monsieur le Président notre thème que
nous souhaitions aborder avec vous dans
cette émission sont les problèmes et
vous l'avez indiqué tout à l'heure de de
l'approvisionnement des céréales de la
filière céréalière vous savez que télé 5
Monde est une chaîne très diffusée dans
toute l'Afrique et la question de la
filière céréalière est au centre de
toutes les préoccupations
particulièrement de ce continent
africain bien sûr Silas babayan qui est
journaliste au magazine Afrique
agriculture à une question à vous poser
à vous directement à ce propos on
l'écoute monsieur le Président vous
savez bien que le blé est vital dans
l'alimentation humaine et surtout dans
les pays d'Afrique il y a un certain
temps de le blé a été débloqué des
cargaisons doublées ont été débloqués
vers l'Afrique j'aimerais savoir sur le
président sia des quantités dans
l'avenir qui vont être envoyées vers ce
pays je vous remercie monsieur le
président
merci
je voudrais faire votre attention
attirez votre attention à deux autres
crises c'est
la crise alimentaire et les conditions
dures d'hiver
à cause des tirs de la Russie sur
l'infrastructure
ukrainienne
la route
maritime a été bloquée ils sont tout
fait ce qu'il pouvait pour nous priver
de la possibilité d'exporter nos blé
c'est nos céréales en général
[Musique]
travailler et améliorer nos voies
ferroviaires mais si on compare les
volumes d'approvisionnement parfois
ferroviaire et parfois maritime la
différence était énorme donc c'est
initiative pour l'exploitation des
céréales va
fonctionner va travailler
jusqu'au moment où les Russie décident
de ne plus le permettre
on s'adressait à nos partenaires pour
recevoir l'armement nécessaire pour
sécuriser les couloirs de l'exportation
de des céréales
vers l'Afrique vers l'Asie et l'Europe
mais les pays de l'Europe
le moindre déficit que les pays de
l'Afrique
nous continuons de rester les 40 heures
de
la sécurité alimentaire dans le monde
va recevoir assez de l'argent au moins
pour que ce soit assez pour pour le
semis de l'année suivante
parce que nous avons assez de céréales
assez de production pour les livrer pour
les exporter vers d'autres pays parce
que nous devons exporter nous devons
exporter cette production nous n'avons
pas assez de bâtiments de stockage pour
les placer à l'Ukraine c'est pourquoi on
demandait les armes spécifiques pour
contrôler les
nous assurons le contrôle
de ses mais il y a des accords avec la
Turquie vous aviez fait justement de la
levée de ce blocus une condition pour
soulager la fin dans le monde
aujourd'hui Vladimir Poutine vous accuse
de vendre les céréales ukrainiennes aux
Européens est-ce que l'accord qui a été
conclu pour une durée de 4 mois est
aujourd'hui menacée et est-ce que vous
avez des négociations ou des échanges
avec les autorités russes actuellement
sur cette question
sur ce sujet
nous avons des accords avec l'oignon
nous sommes en contact avec le président
turcane et c'est assez cela me suffit
pour organiser ce couloirs
les bateaux vers l'Afrique
faire l'Asie
[Musique]
mais c'est la mention que nous employons
nos céréales seulement en Europe
c'est pourquoi les
navires
approvisionne les céréales vers le pays
d'Afrique mais c'est pas vrai que nous
fournissons la majorité de notre la plus
grande partie de nos céréales vers
l'Europe parce qu'ils n'ont pas besoin
par contre les approvisionnent nos
céréales faire l'Afrique
euh les céréales en compagnie
de vente européenne nous assurons aussi
humanitaire
nombre d'autres pays
c'est le soutien monitaire parce qu'ils
ont dit qu'ils n'avaient pas d'argent
nous avons acheté ces céréales et
envoyer dans ces pays l'Ukraine est l'un
des greniers à blés du monde comment
est-ce que se porte l'agriculture
ukrainienne après 7 mois de guerre
surtout dans la région de Carson
dans ses régions qui donnait toujours
beaucoup de récoltes et c'est bien que
le
blastérisa mais on a réussi à organiser
leucémie
on fournissait de l'aide à nos experts
de l'agriculture à nos employés bien sûr
nous avons honte de récoltes cette année
parce que nous avons
prêts à assurer la sécurité
pour les marchés
[Musique]
a besoin de céréales personne n'a bloqué
la prévisionnement de produits agricoles
de la Russie
on pouvait en poser des sanctions
et toutes les ménages
vous vous pourriez vous en parler avec
vos pairs chefs d'État non non pas du
tout
pour l'exportation de céréales
mais ça leur est égal le déficit en Asie
en Afrique le programme alimentaire dans
ce pays
de l'Afrique de l'Asie je voudrais
m'adresser à tous ceux qui nous voient
aujourd'hui
nous avons analyser le marché
nous avons analysé
par la Russie
depuis le début
de la chute de l'Union soviétique
nous avons donc calculer les
investissements de la Russie sur le
continent européen c'est 0,8%
a investi dans les pays du continent
africain
de leur influence mais est-ce qu'ils
l'ont vraiment le monde investissait les
beaucoup d'argent beaucoup plus d'argent
que la Russie tandis que essayer de la
Russie essayer seulement influencer la
Paletti de la politique de ces pays
et aujourd'hui il essaie de bloquer
l'approvisionnement des céréales vous
avez conscience que c'est une âme très
importante la communication
vous pensez que la Russie a réussi à
vous rendre impopulaire en Afrique
est-ce que vous pensez que la Russie
a réussi à faire au fond que que
l'Afrique ne soutiennent pas l'Ukraine
en tout cas un grand nombre de pays
je pense que la Russie a réussi
la guerre des communication depuis le
début de la guerre et nous réussissons à
mener cette guerre nous réussissons à
unir tout le monde mais avant l'invasion
a grande échelle
le crâne
ne menait pas une communication réussie
sur le continent africain
dans la région du Pacifique
etc on a perdu la confiance et la
communication avec plusieurs pays
africains donc au début de la guerre on
a renouvelé ses contacts et on arrive à
communiquer aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que la Russie a beaucoup
d'influence sur les pays de l'Afrique
c'est plus simple pour nous de
communiquer avec le pays de l'Europe
parce que l'Europe est plus proche de
nous mais vous vous le savez vous-même
que l'Europe n'était pas unie sur la
question de l'Ukraine même en 2014
vous savez qu'il y avait
l'annexion de l'imprimée en 2014
et cela n'a pas uni l'Europe
se sentait confiantes de continuer parce
qu'elle n'a pas reçu d'une réponse forte
du monde monsieur le Président
l'armement est une question centrale
dans cette guerre cela semble être même
une forme d'obsession pour vous
l'armement de votre pays
c'est un armement conventionnel ou
sophistiqué qu'il vous faut qui est
essentiel pour gagner cette guerre
notre tâche aujourd'hui est de préserver
la vie de chacun de chaque personne
c'est important pour nous la vie des
gens
principal
et se sont réunis au début de la guerre
comme vous l'avez dit il n'avait pas de
d'armes et il essayait d'arrêter les
Richards juste avec Clément vide
les qualités de nos gens
donc pour nous les technologies les
trones de combat les drôles de
renseignements sont très importants
pour le moment mais nous avons les
Blondé
c'est très peu mais nous les avons
c'est très difficile de mener une guerre
sans lance-roquette multiple multiple
nous les recevons aujourd'hui les Cinq
Mars et les autres systèmes et je peux
remercier la France et le président
Emmanuel Macron parce que les César nous
aide beaucoup ils sont entre meilleurs
c'est ce que je lui ai dit
que tu peux être fier
cela
marche ils sont très bien sur la chambre
de bataille parce qu'il y a les autres
systèmes qui ne
qui ne donne pas les mêmes résultats qui
ne durent pas aussi longtemps
donc maintenant nous pourrons voir
l'efficacité nécessaire dans la guerre
réelle ils sont vraiment de qualité de
haute qualité et ils influencent le
cours de cette guerre
les lance-roquettes multiples et les
chars et les technologies
nous avons besoin ce que nous avons et
ce qui influence le cours de l'écart
parce que nous ne pouvons pas gagner
avec la quantité de gens les Russes sont
toujours plus nombreux
et justement est-ce que dans la
contre-offensive que vous avez récemment
mené à carquive le soutien militaire
américain en termes d'armement en termes
d'entraînement aussi des militaires
Ukrainiens en termes de renseignements a
permis de faire la différence
et la motivation
de nos gens ont été décisifs
non soldats avancé et les soldats russes
étaient en train de fuir
[Musique]
une fois qu'on a reçu l'artillerie
avancer
sans aucun moyen
nous sommes devenus
avec l'armement nous avons réussi dans
la contrefensive Denis
par la France hier le ministre des
Armées Sébastien Lecornu a confirmé que
l'aide militaire de la France et
l'Ukraine va se poursuivre une question
très simple est-ce que la France en fait
assez et qu'est-ce que vous attendiez
que la France fasse de plus
je voudrais que la France fasse des plus
et ce n'est pas une question à propos de
France c'est la concerne tout autre pays
nous avons besoin de plus d'armements
ce sera assez je pense que vous me
comprenez
le président Baden m'a dit que tu
demandes beaucoup mais je te comprends
c'est ce que moi je ferai aussi ta place
donc
je demande beaucoup mais je te comprends
il nous aide
[Musique]
plus encore plus d'armement
il y a je voudrais voir plus de d'actes
résolus décisive de l'Allemagne de la
Turquie et des États-Unis
parce qu'il y a peu de producteurs
d'armement
anti-aériens c'est 5 aussi pays dans le
monde c'est la France c'est l'Allemagne
les États-Unis
nous a promis
de fournir fermement les États-Unis
aussi
je ne sais pas ce qui est arrivé à
Israël
je suis franc et je suis choquée je ne
comprends pas
pourquoi ils ne peuvent pas nous dire
les moyens de défense anti-aérienne
pas suffisamment c'est ce que vous êtes
en train de nous dire
Israël
rien zéro je comprends que leur
situation est difficile
mais j'appelais le 2 dirigeant les deux
premiers ministres d'Israël et je
demandais de nous fournir les moyens de
défense entière
je comprends qu'ils doivent défendre
leur terre mais après j'ai reçu des
informations de nos services de
renseignement
qu'en fait les Israël
approvision c'est moyen de défense dans
d'autres pays
peuvent les vendre ils peuvent les
exporter c'est pourquoi je suis étonnée
comment c'est possible vous savez qu'il
y a la guerre
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup de gens d'origine juifs
en Israël comment c'est possible d'avoir
cette attitude j'étais étonnée donc je
reviens à la France
c'est pourquoi les moyens de défense
entière aériennes et très importantes je
suis très reconnaissante Emmanuel
nous avons vraiment besoin de ces moyens
pour assurer le retour des gens à
l'Ukraine pour que les enfants puissent
aller à l'école les gens puissent
travailler pour que l'économie travaille
la France et l'économie sont des
économies qui nous c'est sûr d'être
prêts
c'est mon cher de nous donner les moyens
de défense entière pour que notre
économie fonctionne de nouveau
ce temps à propos d'Israël c'est
extrêmement intéressant est-ce que vous
pensez que Israël son opinion publique
ces dirigeants politiques sont sensibles
à ce que Vladimir Poutine a dit
également pour avant de déclencher cette
offensive contre vous
dénonçant un régime nazi en Ukraine
dénonçant une idéologie d'extrême droite
est-ce que vous pensez que ça a porté
sur l'opinion publique israélienne et
sur les dirigeants israéliens ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui vous vous n'avez
plus ou pas de contact avec eux et qui
ne vous fournissent pas d'armes est-ce
que vous est-ce que c'est quelque chose
auquel vous avez naturellement pensé
en public il ne s'agit pas de la société
d'Israël par rapport à la société je le
connais très bien je visiter Israël pour
des dizaines de fois la société est pour
le prenne il ne se tiennent et sont les
gens
de la nature
qui ont su montrer comment bâtir un état
les dirigeants vous mettez en cause les
dirigeants israéliens
je constate je constate le fait
il y avait des discussions avec les
leaders d'Israël et cela n'a pas aidé à
l'Ukraine
entre le dirigeants de l'Israël et de la
Russie et on peut remarquer l'influence
de la Russie sur l'Israël et moi je
considère l'Israël en état puissant en
grande état qui est complètement
indépendant dans leur prise de décision
et je sais que l'opinion publique en
Israël est différente ils sont pour le
crâne et soutiennent le crâne
pourquoi vous ne pouvez pas nous donner
les moyens de défense entière c'est pour
se défendre ce contre les missiles
ils le comprennent très bien
que le crâne n'a pas approvisionner de
ce type d'armement
quand il en avait besoin mais je
t'explique maintenant que le prenne n'a
pas
nous ne l'avons pas l'armée
ukrainienne a réussi une
contre-offensive et Claire remarquable
avec 8500 km² libérée mais vous détenez
un vous donner un décompte précis des
pertes des soldats russes et du matériel
détruit est-ce que vous allez maintenir
le secret défense sur les pertes
ukrainiennes en soldats jusqu'à la fin
de la guerre
et pourquoi
et qu'est-ce qui vous motive pourquoi
donc la position de nommer les terres et
de ne pas fournir les chiffres exacts de
militaire et clients qui ont été tués au
blessés vous avez raison à dire que nous
fournissons les chiffres exacts à propos
de français donc la question sur la
motivation vous demandez ce qui motive
vous ne voulez pas révéler ces chiffres
parce qu'ils sont trop importants ils
sont plus importants vous ne pensiez au
départ du conflit est-ce que vous vous
êtes trompé dans l'approche
la question principale
c'est les données exactes
j'ai les données que j'ai reçus
qu'il faut être très prudent avec les
chiffres parce qu'il s'agit de vie
humaine
nous savons très bien
un village par exemple était occupé
nous recevons les chiffres que par
exemple
300 personnes ont été fait prisonniers
ensuite
nous avançons dans la région de quartier
la ville de Lyon par exemple et nous
voyons
[Musique]
45 personnes dans le forêt des humains
nous trouvons également 20 militaires
torturés et tués
donc nous n'avons pas de chiffres exacts
pour aujourd'hui nous avons des chiffres
qui concernent
certains quartiers de nos pays qui sont
en guerre qui sont occupés
nous avons des estimations de pertes par
jour
ils ne sont pas exactes mais ce sont les
estimations des pertes de nos militaires
dans les directions des actes défensifs
et offensive vous pouvez nous donner un
chiffre une approximation vous pouvez
nous donner un chiffre à
petites personnes par jour
combien de gens militaires et combien de
gens civils restent réellement sur le
territoire la quantité des personnes qui
sont mortes
comme prisonniers qui ont des torturés
ou tués
[Musique]
il y a moins de militaires que que des
militaires russes
cinq fois moins monsieur le Président
nous allons maintenant parler de
l'Ukraine de votre pays et de ses
relations avec l'Union européenne
nous avons un ancien ministre des
Affaires étrangères français qui a été
commissaire européen qui s'est occupé de
négocier le brexit Michel Barnier
capture question à vous poser en duplex
de télé 5 Michelier ski bonjour je viens
de consacrer cinq années à une
négociation
négative celle d'un divorce le brexit
c'est une perspective autrement plus
positive et plus constructive que celle
de l'adhésion d'un grand pays l'Ukraine
à l'Union européenne vous avez désormais
avec l'accord des chefs d'États
européens du Parlement européen le
statut de pays candidat
ma question est simple cette guerre va
s'arrêter grâce à la détermination
volontarisme au courage politique dont
vous faites preuve avec le peuple
ukrainien au delà de l'arrêt de cette
guerre et du cessez-le-feu que nous
espérons proches il faudra construire
cette perspective européenne et il
travaillait ma question est de savoir
selon vous selon ce que vous souhaitez
selon ce qui vous paraît possible
combien de temps dans quel délai vous
pensez être prêt sachant l'état
difficile de votre pays dans cette
guerre la reconstruction mais aussi
sachant les conditions qu'il faut
remplir pour adhérer dans combien de
temps espérez-vous pensez-vous être prêt
adhérer à l'Union européenne
merci pour votre question je voudrais
diviser cette question en deux parties
d'abord sur la reconstruction de notre
pays
et après sur
l'adhésion à l'Union européenne je vous
remercie de nous de votre soutien je
vous remercie de votre travail
le crâne
à cette respiration de devenir le membre
de l'Union européenne depuis plusieurs
années
et je pense que
nous sommes
vraiment très très proche de cette
perspective d'adhésion à l'Union
européenne je voudrais remercier
également
l'Union européenne et le président
Macron parce que nous avons obtenu le
statut de candidats dont la période de
la présidente française dans l'Union
européenne nous sommes très
reconnaissants pour ceux qui ont
est prête à adhérer à l'Union européenne
c'est ce que je pense
que la question est si l'Union
européenne
et la plupart des pays
mais sont prêts il y a bien sûr les
conditions que le crâne doit accomplir
nous devons synchroniser nos systèmes
législatif
nous travaillons
la coalition et l'opposition mais nous
ne sommes jamais divisés sur la
perspective européenne
de l'Ukraine cela ne se munit sur cette
question et je vais être franc
maintenant
à l'Union européenne
dans le Parlement ukrainien et ça se
passe très très vite
tout ce qui concerne la législation
anticorruption
la synchronisation de nos législations
avec les gestation de l'Union européenne
tout ça est en train de se poursuivre en
Ukraine
ne seront prêtes très très vite et ce
sera l'Union européenne avec toutes les
normes qui imposent à l'Ukraine qui sont
imposées à l'Ukraine pour entrer dans
l'Union européenne et ceux vous nous
dites aujourd'hui rapidement
bien sûr s'il y a des complications
dans la guerre ce sera ça peut être
compliqué de voter dans le Parlement
c'est le seul difficulté qui peut nous
arriver
dans ce cas ça va prendre pas 3 mois
mais six mois mais je parle pas des
années mais des mois
et je pense qu'on doit compenser la
reconstruction aujourd'hui parce qu'il y
a l'infrastructure qui doit être
reconstruire maintenant parce que les
enfants ils vont à l'école
les écoles maternelles nous devons
renouveler et construire notre
infrastructure et le foyer pour les
Européens toujours l'énergie est une
question absolument centrale surtout
l'approche de l'hiver
Patrice Moyon question là-dessus la
guerre la guerre entre la Russie et
l'Ukraine a provoqué une crise
énergétique sans précédent en Europe
évidemment les français s'inquiètent
mais vous en Ukraine comment est-ce que
vous vous préparez à cet hiver est-ce
que vous aurez suffisamment de gaz
est-ce que vous aurez suffisamment
d'électricité est-ce que vous aurez
besoin du soutien aussi de l'Europe pour
passer cette hiver
il y a proche
je ne pense pas que la gare a provoqué
la crise énergétique en Europe en
Ukraine et en Europe c'est la Russie qui
a provoqué bien avant l'invasion
inconditionnel
c'était quand quand la Russie a commencé
à
augmenter les prix
a commencé à contrôler de manière
artificielle les prix
de l'énergie en grimpé
j'ai parlé déjà de l'électricité et que
le crâne propre approvisionner en Europe
parce que nos exportons de l'énergie
nous on nous recevons
de l'argent pour notre économie mais la
Russie va faire tout pour quelle
centrale des apparitions ne fonctionne
pas pour que nous sommes privés de
l'électricité
qu'on ne puisse pas l'approvisionner
dans d'autres pays de l'Europe
que la Russie crée
plusieurs dirigeants y compris la
pression Macron
de
retirer l'armement et les troupes russes
de la centrale
de la centrale seulement tous les
militaires doivent quitter ce site de
Sabri Jean seulement les employés de
l'important doivent être sur la centrale
sur le réseau
ne seront
relancer la centrale
monsieur le Président voient les
conséquences sur leur vie quotidienne en
France comme ailleurs l'énergie est plus
rare elle est plus chère et les
Européens ne font pas nécessairement la
différence dans les responsabilités
entre ce qui relève des Ukrainiens et
des Russes est-ce que vous ne craignez
pas que la situation qui impacte les
Français dans leur vie quotidienne les
Français et les Européens
fassent faiblir le soutien que vous
apporte la population européenne
le soutien de l'Ukraine
reçoivent de l'information partielle si
elle comprenne toute la situation dans
son intégralité
s'il comprennent la position de la
Russie
réviser l'initiative pour la cooptation
des céréales
on doit le faire
nous devons
survivre c'est l'hiver parce que
sinon
nous ne pourrons pas survivre dans les
années suivantes nous devons être
indépendants
indépendant de tous les restrictions
éventuelles que la Russie peut
introduire et l'économie ukrainienne
évidemment est extrêmement important
dans cette affaire Armel Le Goff oui les
enjeux sont grands l'Ukraine a été en
partie détruit et sur le plan économique
cela votre conseiller économique le PIB
pourrait être en baisse de 40% et le
déficit atteindre 40 milliards de
dollars en 2023 alors reconstruire une
économie comment reconstruire un pays
5 milliards
par mois
au début de l'année suivante ce sera
trois virgule cinq meilleurs de déficit
c'est ce que nous pouvons faire
nous-même
nous ne pouvons pas éliminer
complètement le déficit budgétaire
nous devons
donner la possibilité pourtant pour les
gens de revenir à l'Ukraine
il y a beaucoup de gens déplacés
dans leur foyer
ils doivent revenir et continuer leur
travail pour payer les impôts qui
remplit
ce qui nous donnera la possibilité de
reconstruire le pays de
[Musique]
et comme j'ai déjà dit nous avons le
soutien de cinq ou six pays qui nous
peuvent donner les moyens pour
assurer la
sécurité dans l'air qui peuvent nous
donner des moyens de défense entière
nous demandons aussi les pays européen
de nos fournir les moyens qui ne sont
pas tout neufs peut-être qu'ils sont
assis
mais nous en avons besoin maintenant
pour assurer notre sécurité dans l'air
pour assurer que notre économie
fonctionne
très bien
ce que les systèmes de défense entière
aérienne dans le pays
européen
et c'est comme ça qu'on peut éviter le
déficitairement aussi au chef
d'entreprise en Europe que vous incitez
à venir vous aider à reconstruire
l'Ukraine quand cette guerre sera
terminée vous avez fait un appel
récemment au Medef qui est le syndicat
français des patrons français de
participer à cette reconquête
est-ce que vous n'avez pas peur au fond
que
le monde entier se dise que ce sont les
Américains qui vous profitez de
l'après-guerre en Ukraine et qu'il y
aura peu de place
pour les autres pays
comme les américains vous êtes beaucoup
demanderont-ils des compensations après
cette guerre
au contraire
nous demandons les États-Unis
d'ambulanciers également
nous nous sommes ouverts à n'importe
quel
entrepreneurs
aujourd'hui et demain ce sont les les
places de travail
de reconstruction
mais c'est aussi utile pour vous aussi
c'est bien pour tout le monde s'il y a
des grands projets il n'y a pas de
projet de tel un coeur de reconstruction
dans
21ème siècle
pour pour les entrepreneurs
l'énergie nous sommes très ouverts
[Musique]
les places de travail aujourd'hui et
donc le sud client vont avoir du travail
et vont payer les impôts nous nous
invitons également les États-Unis et les
pays européennes
c'est pourquoi c'est très utile c'est
très bien pour créer le
les projets à l'Ukraine
c'est très utile pour le monde
d'affaires européen alors monsieur le
président
avant d’aborder la question des
alliances et du dialogue qui est
absolument capital pour vous pour
l'Ukraine à ce moment il y a des zones
du monde où l'on subit moins on va dire
les conséquences de cette guerre ou tout
au moins différemment je propose que
nous partions quelques secondes pour les
Caraïbes ou Cyril Boutier notre
partenaire de France Antilles à une
question à vous poser à ce sujet bonjour
monsieur le Président nos territoires
sont des territoires occidentaux mais
géographiquement positionnés en Amérique
du Sud pour la Guyane dans le bassin
caribéen tout proche des États-Unis pour
les Antilles selon vous quel rôle
peuvent-ils jouer géopolitiquement
pas nos messages
pas de l'information de la part de
l'Ukraine parce que le crâne n'était pas
présente dans cette région auparavant et
c'est notre horreur c'est notre horreur
et l'influence de la Russie
de ne pas avoir été assez présent avant
la guerre bien sûr
dans les régions je pense que c'est une
horreur de la diplomatie ukrainienne pas
de la société iranienne mais de des
autorités
ukrainiennes c'est vrai
c'était le plan faible dans les
stratégie diplomatiques de crinienne
parce que travailler avec les États-Unis
et les pays européennes
mais je voudrais vous dire que dans
plusieurs régions du monde dans dans les
pays africains les pays d'Haïti les
Caraïbes
tous les gens qui ont réussi
qui
ont réussi dans la vie il faisait leurs
études à une femme et il y a aussi les
gens qui faisaient leur situation
[Musique]
donc
cette éducation et ils sont partis pour
leur pays on a perdu de contact
et après c'est la Russie qui qui en
profite qui exercait son influence c'est
pourquoi aujourd'hui il a été très
important de trouver un plateau en
formationnel le plateau médiatique
au niveau différent au niveau du
président du Premier ministre de nos
communautés de nos concitoyens de nos
militaires de nos médecins il faut
qu'ils apparaissent sur sur le plateau
qui peuvent être visibles pour pour se
payer longtemps pour que les sociétés
dans tous les régions du monde
apprennent la vérité notre tâche
de faire comprendre
parce que la personne est assez sage je
suis intelligente pour comprendre tout
et même on fournit des informations
nous donnons des possibilités
d'observatoire d'obtenir les
informations
de vraies informations et puis prendre
la décision à ce propos monsieur le
Président dans les alliances dans le
dialogue la Chine grand pays à une
position ambiguë depuis le début dans
cette guerre si j'ai une Ping a
rencontré Vladimir Poutine en
Ouzbékistan le 15 septembre dernier
existe-t-il encore aujourd'hui un canal
de discussion avec siipping entre vous
et le président chinois est-ce que le
dialogue est maintenu sous une forme ou
sous une autre
comment vous parlez au chinois à quel
niveau et comment aujourd'hui ce canal
est il maintenu ou non
il y avait des canaux de communication
entre nos pays sur le niveau différent
au niveau différent et le commerce entre
les pays en témoignent
on a fait une beaucoup de coopération
économique commerciale avec avec la
Chine
on allait se déclinks
de discussion de communication avec
ce pays pour le moment on n'a pas de
canal de communication avec la Chine et
c'est dommage
moi je pense que c'est un grand pays qui
est très puissant il peut influencer la
Russie la Russie fait attention à la
Chine et je voudrais que la Chine soit
nous soutien
que la Chine prend la position
ambiguë il essaie de balancer et c'est
d'être au milieu je vois qu'ils ne
vendent pas d'armes à la Russie
par le fait même qu'il n'aime pas de
pas leur Russie qu'ils ne vendent pas
d'armes à la Russie
mais je reconnais que qu'on ne maintient
pas de
très bonnes relations avec la Chine nous
n'avons pas de relation en tout cas que
je voudrais je pense qu'il serait que ce
serait très important
je pense que tout le monde doit se
réunir et faire le récit terminé cette
guerre je pense que les acteurs les plus
puissants c'est les États-Unis les
compétences et la Chine
Bing vous n'auriez pas de réponse
[Musique]
on se parlait on avait des conversations
normales tout à fait normal on parlait
de nos relations bilatérales
je pense que ce serait difficile à faire
aujourd'hui
nous allons partir pour Nice monsieur le
Président
Nice-Matin dont le dirigeant de
rédaction est avec nous aujourd'hui a
rencontré une réfugiée ukrainienne qui
vit à Nice une ville que vous connaissez
vous avez visité Nice dans une autre vie
vous étiez acteur elle a une question à
vous poser sur le retour de vos
concitoyens ici en Ukraine bonjour
monsieur le Président
je veux savoir qu'est-ce que vous pensez
qu'est-ce que vos présupposez pour la
rentrée de nos enfants après la guerre à
cause de
beaucoup d'écoles étaient détruits
complètement et qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez
[Musique]
nous avons le plan de reconstruction de
notre pays et le plan rapide de
reconstruction de notre pays et les
infrastructures
les écoles doivent être reconstruits en
premier lieu
nous avons peu de moyens dans notre but
pour le moment
on avait ce programme on présentait ce
programme aux États-Unis et à l'Union
européenne ont demandé de l'aide dans
cette reconstruction
de l'infrastructure médicale et des
établissements d'enseignement aussi ont
demandé trois virgule six milliards de
dollars c'est une grande décembre pour
nous
nous essayons de reconstruire les écoles
papa de construire les abris anti-bombes
pour les élèves
donc nous sommes en train de
reconstruire toute l'infrastructure
parce que nous comprenons les défis et
les menaces
Ukrainiens pourtant en âge de combattre
ont trouvé refuge sur la Côte d'Azur à
Monaco les considérez-vous comme des
traîtres et avez-vous engagé des
poursuites à leur rencontre
il y a la question de législation et il
y a la question de morale
en ce qui concerne le moral
c'est difficile pour moi de d'évoluer de
se prononcer sur les décisions d'autres
pays moi j'ai pas de questions c'était
leur droit
permettez-moi de ne pas dire ce que je
pense de chacun d'eux de ces gens
je ne peux pas généraliser peut-être
quelqu'un avait peur quelqu'un devait
évacuer les enfants quelqu'un
avait d'autres raisons
je pense que
en ce qui concerne ceux qui ont
pas respecté la législation ils vont
être tenus responsables mais ce n'est
pas la question à moi nous arrivons
bientôt au terme de cette émission
monsieur le Président et je voudrais
qu'on parle de questions un peu
personnelles avant que nous nous
quittions
comment vous replongez-vous dans une vie
normale est-ce que vous voulez
[Musique]
donc nous nous prenons le cours de cette
émission votre conseiller à nous a
demandé de conclure l'émission vous avez
évidemment beaucoup d'engagements et qui
nous comprenons donc
vous vous replongez de temps en temps
dans les poèmes de ce héros national ta
race stevensko qui est considéré ici
comme un héros national je le disais et
vous savez que l'acteur Alain Delon a
décidé de s'engager pour l'Ukraine et de
réciter de refaire l'acteur à 86 ans
pour réciter des poèmes de ta race
stevensko je vous propose 10 secondes de
regarder Alain Delon et de tendre la
question de son éditeur français
j'inspirais
quand je serai mort
mettez-moi dans le théâtre qui sert de
tombe au milieu de la pleine immense
dans mon Ukraine bien-aimée
monsieur le Président permettez-moi tout
d'abord de vous témoigner notre
admiration et notre soutien au peuple
ukrainien et à vous-même ce fut une
grande fierté pour les éditions seguères
et le groupe éditisme de republier ses
poèmes de table ils ont été élu avec
force par Alain Delon et j'espère que
tout le monde francophone les connaîtra
ma question est simple comment dans
cette période si éprouvante
t'arrache les chenko sévère sa poésie
vous accompagne au quotidien
merci pour la question
merci pour la maison d'édition pour
avoir publié
ce verbe cette poésie qu'il popularise
les poèmes
Ukrainiens de ta réception en français
c'est très important pour nous
je vais être franche je veux dire que
nous nous connaissons la littérature
française nous la prenons à l'école
Jules Verne
je veux dire que nos écoles nos
universités nous ont donné la
possibilité d'apprendre le littérature
française et les Ukrainiens aiment la
littérature française et c'est très très
bien que les maisons d'édition française
montrent que la littérature ukrainienne
existe en France aussi je voudrais aussi
que les
enfants Français sachent la littérature
écrite
la littérature française
je pense que
c'est ça le sens de nos relations
générales je pense que c'est ça va être
très utile pour les enfants
français alors des longs c'est un grand
acteur tout le monde en Ukraine connaît
la langue
les films les travaux de cet acteur et
j'étais très
période de parler avec lui nous sommes
fans de l'intello pour les femmes
surtout c'est
pas une femme
mais
vraiment une vedette
une ancienne balle
30 personnes
je suis très reconnaissante
on peut
se parler et ne comprend pas
pourquoi les gens et les animaux sont
tués je suis très reconnaissant
l'intello pour sa position très ferme
très forte
la poésie les poésie de chez une quoi
est présente dans ma vie
tout le monde en Ukraine connaît
les poèmes de chenko et elle est
toujours actuelle et il est toujours
pertinent
et tout le monde connaît les paroles
célèbres que nous devons
se battre
lutter et
vous vaincre
il est toujours pertinent à l'école à
l'université nous le voyons
sera diffusé dans quelques semaines sur
les écrans de télévision en France et
sur bien sûr TV5 Monde monsieur le
Président nous allons vous quitter
maintenant
dans un instant nous allons
montrer un dialogue que vous avez
souhaité avoir avec Alain Delon qui a
été enregistré il y a très peu de jours
quelques jours lui était dans les
studios de TV5 Monde à Paris vous vous
étiez ici à cette même place à Kiev nous
allons diffuser dans quelques instants
cet entretien entre deux anciens acteurs
lui est un ancien acteur qui est
retirait de par son âge vous êtes un
ancien acteur de métier ça vous a aidé
d'être un acteur dans cette situation
tragique on vous a qualifié de grands
communicateurs est-ce que ça compte dans
l'art de la guerre d'être un grand
communicateur est-ce que ça a pas été
non plus critique qu'on vous a faites de
trop savoir de trop vouloir communiquer
vous avez parlé de l'armement
aujourd'hui
et j'ai répondu que
je
réclame les armes contemporaines qui
peut être décisif et je pense que la
communication
c'est une arme décisive aussi
et si vous dites que je suis un bon
communicateur
donc je comprends cette arme et je pense
qu'elle renforce notre pays et uni nos
sociétés
merci infiniment de nous avoir reçu ici
dans votre palais présidentiel très
sécurisé à Kiev merci pour les
téléspectateurs de TV5 Monde de par le
monde et les téléspectateurs LCI en
France qui ont diffusé dans les
conditions du direct cette émission
merci je parlais de LCP la Chaîne
parlementaire française de l'Assemblée
nationale bien sûr merci Patrice Moyon
de Ouest-France merci Denis carro de
Nice-Matin merci Armel Le Goff de 20
minutes monsieur le Président si vous
voulez bien maintenant nous allons
regarder le dialogue que vous avez eu il
y a quelques jours avec Alain Delon deux
acteurs
vous un ancien acteur lui un ancien
acteur se parle et échange sur votre
situation aujourd'hui la situation du
crâne merci de nous avoir reçu Monsieur
le Président
merci beaucoup pour possibilité que vous
êtes venus moi je n'ai pas de
possibilités en France
mais ce serait un grand plaisir pour moi
de venir à Paris
je remercie encore une fois au
journaliste qui aide à
donner des informations et le soutien de
votre société merci nous allons vous
regarder vous entretenir avec Alain
Delon il y a quelques jours lui depuis
Paris vous depuis cette place ici même à
Kiev
bonjour
c'est très simple
de vous
on l'a souvent dit qu'on était bouée
bois des frères
alors je suis d'accord on a peut-être
commencé correcteur tout ce que ça c'est
que moi je ne suis plus acteur et vous
êtes président quand même mieux merci
merci de recevoir un ancien acteur
il y a toujours
plus belle personne carrière que la
mienne il est Président je suis rien du
tout
croyez-moi je vous aime beaucoup nous
vous respectons et pour moi vous avez
toujours été vous êtes toujours une
autorité et un immense acteur nous
connaissons vos films ces films sont
cités bien que seuls films en langue
française nous vous avons entendu aussi
bien en traduction qu'en originale mais
Alain Delon
un immense acteur et la France je suis
certaine
fier de son acteur vous voyez je suis
devenu président et maintenant j'ai la
possibilité de parler à Alain Delon
lui-même
je ferais mieux vous parler
[Rires]
je suis heureux de vous voir je suis
très content vraiment ça me fait très
plaisir à cause de vous et à cause du
crâne vraiment
je vous remercie je sais quel est votre
attitude à l'égard de l'Ukraine
de cette guerre il y a de jeux et je
suis
maintenant très heureux que vous stagnez
nos gens
c'est très important pour nous
aujourd'hui
lorsque les gens célèbrent
car la parole est une arme et parfois
frappe plus fort qu'une arme réelle sur
un champ de bataille par conséquent le
soutien des gens qu'on vous est très
important pour nous et je vous en
remercie infiniment
que je puisse faire parce que je pouvais
faire plus que pas je ferai plus que ça
parce que vous méritez pas tout ce que
vous vivez vous Galvez pas ce que vivre
l'Ukraine en ce moment et ce que vit
votre peuple
absolument absolument
les gens le mal vient aussi des gens
russes sur notre sol la façon dont il se
comporte torture ça dépasse les règles
de la guerre
[Musique]
ce sont juste des enfants inoffensifs
ils ne sont parfaitement conscients vous
et moi quelle est la différence entre le
cinéma et la tragédie que nous vivons
aujourd'hui car au cinéma même la
tragédie
sur une heure et demie deux heures et
tout cela prend fin alors que cette
guerre malheureusement
nous avons le sentiment que cette guerre
est infinie
cela fait 8 ans que elle dure et presque
six mois d'une guerre à grande échelle
et nous espérons beaucoup qu'elle
prendra rapidement fin
avec vous j'espère pour vous parce que
c'est tout ce que vous méritez de mieux
au monde c'est à dire s'arrête je
voulais rien fait pour la provoquer rien
fait pour l'avoir vraiment je ne
comprends pas je dis les choses que je
ne comprends pas et cette guerre je ne
l'accepte pas
et quand je vous vois ce qui vous est ce
que vous souffrez tous les jours de ce
peuple qui crève de ses enfants qui
meurent de ces animaux qui trépassent ça
me dégoûte
vraiment ça me dégoûte je suis heureux
de vous le dire
alors
je vous remercie beaucoup de votre
compréhension de ce soutien
qui est important ce soutien est
important pour nos gens
toute notre population ils vont entendre
cela peut-être ils ont besoin d'être
motivés et d'avoir envie de vivre et
lorsque cela dure les gens perdent cette
envie de vivre ils ont le sentiment que
cela ne finira jamais les gens se
défendent bien sûr là vous avez
parfaitement raison nous nous défendons
je pense que les gens qui tuent
sans doute une raison
et trouve une justification à leurs
actes
ils ne le font pas comme ça gratuitement
un objectif et cherche à poursuivre
les respects
[Musique]
une nation à part que nous ne sommes pas
des gens différents ils pensent que nous
faisons partie
de son monde
considère ou peut-être il a envie de
retour de l'Union soviétique on
considère en tout cas de son point de
vue c'est juste et
tous ceux qui l'empêchent sur ce chemin
ce n'est que de la chair à canon
objective parfaitement conscient de ce
qu'il fait il s'est parfaitement combien
de personnes périssent tous les jours il
connaît tout jusqu'au moindre détail
mais ça fait partie de son plan c'est
une approche colonialiste
c'est pas d'un pays ou d'une nation
c'est le rêve d'un seul homme vous savez
ça quand même
il a obligé
l'ensemble de sa nation ou la majeure
partie de cette nation à y croire
obligé à se joindre
je me révolte
d'un citoyen britannique ce corps était
démembré il y a une partie du corps qui
manquait je ne sais pas comment ça
dépasse l'entendement si l'on tué
pourquoi
ils ont-ils transmis le corps avec des
parties manquantes pourquoi font-ils
cela qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent prouver je
n'arrive pas à comprendre cette attitude
nous faire peur avec cela mais bien au
contraire ça ne provoque pas la peur
tout le monde comprend qu'on ne peut
plus parler à ces gens après cela c'est
du terrorisme ce n'est plus de la guerre
c'est du terrorisme pour vous
inimaginable je suis vraiment
avec vous
mais
je vous remercie infiniment ça nous est
vraiment nécessaire il est important
pour nous aujourd'hui d'entendre une
voix et à une épaule une main
de quelqu'un de votre trempe
au monde qui pense que c'est monstrueux
merci c'est vrai je vous remercie
beaucoup et Dieu merci il y a d'autres
personnes qui s'engagent et qui
soutiennent l'Ukraine
j'aurais 50 ans de plus je l'engagerai
dans l'armée
50 ans de moins
noté
dans notre capitale venez si vous avez
le temps et la possibilité je serai
absolument ravie de vous recevoir et les
gens seront ravis de vous voir je vous
remercie
j'aurais moins une canne et que je
marche normalement je viendrai
sinon pas longtemps parce que vraiment
ça mérite le déplacement croyez-moi
j'ai pas peur de ça
je sais que vous n'avez pas peur je vous
remercie beaucoup
nous allons vous attendre merci
merci beaucoup
voilà c'est un grand honneur pour moi
véritablement un grand honneur de faire
votre connaissance je vous en remercie
du fond du cœur
voilà cet échange entre Alain Delon et
volo Dimi zellens qui le président
ukrainien qui a été enregistré il y a
quelques jours dans les studios de TV5
Monde à Paris le président zenenski
était ici à cette place là même à Kiev
le Président nous a quitté vous imaginez
la journée qui l'attend ici à Kiev je
suis toujours ici sur ce plateau avec
Patrice Mauillon de Ouest-France avec
Denis carro Denis ce matin et avec Armel
Le Goff de 20 minutes très rapidement en
quelques minutes qu'avez-vous pensé de
cette interview du président Wallonie
avec Mohamed le goffondrer mais il était
extrêmement disponible struction et dans
ses réponses il a donné par exemple un
chiffre qu'il a volontairement décrit
comme approximatif du nombre de
personnes tuées dans le conflit
quotidiennement un chiffre que jusqu'à
présent il n'avait pas donné
approx effectivement autour de 50
personnes en moyenne tous les jours il
était structuré dans ses réponses et sur
les priorités de son pays concernant la
reconstruction la reconstruction de
l'économie dans la perspective d'une
adhésion à l'Union européenne et puis
l'armement l'armement surtout qui
évidemment une priorité absolue pour son
pays et pour le combat qu'il mène face à
la Russie et concernant ce sujet il a
aussi été très clair il dit clairement
les conventions militaires et
humanitaires ne valent pas dans le
contexte dans lequel nous sommes parce
que nous sommes en état de guerre face à
un adversaire qui ne respecte aucune
convention Patrice Noyon alors moi ce
qui m'a ce qui m'a frappé effectivement
c'est s'affranchise il répond il répond
directement aux questions et quand il a
pas répondu et qu'on revient il
donne il donne la réponse ce qui m'a
intéressé c'est ce qu'il a dit sur la
question des armes à sous-munition en
disant d'abord il a il a démenti que
l'Ukraine n'en ai utilisé mais il a dit
que s'il en avait il les utiliserait
tout de même
donc ça c'est ça ça prise de position
est intéressante et puis ce qu'il a dit
aussi sur la diplomatie ukrainienne sur
la question qui lui était posée des
Antilles on a fait une erreur de pas on
aurait l'Ukraine aurait dû s'intéresser
à cette région
qu'on avait en face de nous et c'est pas
c'est pas vraiment une surprise c'est un
chef de guerre bien évidemment mais
c'est aussi et peut-être autant le
principal communicant le communicant en
chef de de son pays en nous recevant on
voit qu'il a voulu s'adresser au monde
envoyer des messages au monde et aux
Européens il a martelé les messages
notamment sur l'armement et la nécessité
de livrer davantage davantage d'armes il
entre beaucoup dans le détail on voit
son son besoin de faire oeuvre de
pédagogie et c'était assez vrai sur la
question de la crise énergétique avec ce
petit risque que les Européens finissent
par
soutenir un peu moins l'Ukraine et ce
des solidariser en raison des
conséquences sur sur leur vie
quotidienne merci donc Nice-Matin West
France 20 minutes nous partenaires
également de la montagne Centre France
vous pouvez retrouver ainsi que celui de
France anti d'ailleurs cette interview
du président ski sur les sites internet
de nos partenaires donc de la presse
quotidienne régionale présent avec nous
ici à Kef pour ma part j'ai noté à la
fin de cette interview avec le président
ski que lorsqu'on parlait de son
ancienne vie celle d'acteurs sont
sourire revenaient par rapport au
sérieux qui a présidé à l'ensemble de la
discussion de cet échange que nous avons
eu ici à Kiev voilà vous pouvez
retrouver évidemment cette émission sur
LCP la Chaîne parlementaire de
l'Assemblée nationale qui nous a diffusé
et qui le rediffusera et également en
replay sur TV5 Monde plus la plateforme
numérique de notre chaîne ainsi bien sûr
que sur les différentes antennes les 9
antennes de TV5 Monde à travers le monde
voilà il est temps de nous quitter je
voudrais remercier particulièrement Tom
Benoît et Vanessa chahane qui ont
présidé à la rédaction chef de cette
émission je vous remercie Yves Bigot
Nicolas renard Pascal Quentin de TV5
Monde évidemment Bertrand delay les
équipes de LCP également Manuel Pinto et
puis ce cette coproduction que nous
avons pu monter grâce aussi à Joseph
araquelle merci depuis Kiev au revoir à
tous et à très vite pour un prochain
numéro de face au territoire
[Musique]